[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خلوا كل واد
ومجراه قاعده من قواعد اهالينا رحمهم الله
في فن التعامل مع الطبيعه
وقوانينها مفادها ان نتجنب الجلوس والنزول
والبناء في بطون الاوديه ومجاري الشعاب
صيفا وشتاء ففي الصيف مراتي على الهوام
وفي الشتاء مجاريا للاوديه لانها تمثل
خطوره بالغه على قاطنيها فاكبر وادي
بالعالم يسمى بوادي الرمه سمي بهذا لانه
هرم اياك الكل اللي جالس بطريقه فلها حرمه
ويجب ان نحترم حرمتها بعدما التخطيط
والبناء والنزول واحترز لفضا وتجنب صحبه
الحمقاء وارباب الخلل انا مثل الماء سهل
ومتى احمي هذا
وقتل
والاودي انواع ومن اخطرها التي تعيش بين
ثنايا الجبال والمرتفعات كجبال تهامه
وعسير ومرتفعات اليمن وسلطنه عمان فلها
قوه جارفه ومن قوتها انها تجرف الصخور ولا
يحج قوته الا البحر والقيلوله لا تكون الا
بعز الغيظ والقيط ما به مطر والعامه
يقولون لا تنام بالمسيل
لو المجيد
[موسيقى]